For this first one, translations represent movements. Just like vectors can be
summed together to make a single movement vector, translations can be multiplied
together to get a single translation. The order that we add the vectors doesn't
matter. Likewise, translation order among translations doesn't matter. So the
answer is yes. Rotation order certainly does matter. Reversing the order will
normally change the effect. So this second question's answer is no. For scaling,
each access scale is independent of the others. If you stretch an object along
the y-axis, its x and z coordinates do not change. Because each is independent,
there is no danger of the scales interacting with each other. Each axes' scale
factors can simply be multiplied together. Multiplication is commutative, so the
scales can be done in any order. Yes. For this last question, say you rotate
around the y-axis and translate along the same axis. The rotations can be done
in any order, since each is just an angle change around the y-axis. The rotation
affects the x and z coordinates of any point transformed. Translation affects
only the y coordinates. Since these are independent values, rotations and
translations along the axis can be evaluated in any order. So the answer here is
yes.